>From our discussion of
human color vision,
we know what's going on with the r,
g, and b in the color class.
But what's this alpha thing?
Alpha is another component of
a color that computers use for
compositing, which is
a fancy way of saying,
what happens when you draw
stuff on top of other stuff?
If you draw a shape with alpha equals
one, then it's totally opaque.
Whatever the background color was,
it's totally gone.
If you draw a shape with alpha equals
zero,then you haven't actually
changed anything.
The new color is totally transparent.
If alpha equals .5, then the new color
is half the background color and
half your new color.
So your drawing looks translucent.
For now, we're going to be
drawing everything fully opaque.
So any time you see an alpha field,
just set it to one.